Welcome back!
I'm here with my panel.
First up, Nightly Show
contributor Mike Yard.
(cheering and applause)
And Nightly Show contributor
Jordan Carlos.
-(cheering and applause)
-Hello. Yes.
And he's performing through June
at Joe's Pub at the Public
in New York City, very funny
French comedian Gad Elmaleh.
(cheering and applause)
Yeah. And for everyone at home,
join our conversation right now
on Twitter, @NightlyShow,
using the hashtag #Tonightly.
Um, so as I mentioned earlier,
um, Iowa caucus is tonight.
-Yes. -Exciting. -So I think
that probably as we're here,
I'm sure the results are-are in.
What was that?
-It's exciting times.
-It's exciting. -Yeah.
-Can you feel it? -We're gonna
find out. We're gonna find out.
-Ooh. -Entertaining. Yeah.
Entertaining. -Yeah, I know.
I do want to talk about one
of the issues of the election.
Uh, how people keep saying anger
is driving this election.
So let's accept that
as a premise.
What are people so angry about?
-What are people so angry about
in this? -Mm-hmm.
Uh, I-I think Americans love
to be outraged anyway.
I mean, they're outraged...
Right?
That the McRib only comes once
a year, you know? That's...
-that's... -I thought...
I thought French people
-would be like this. -Yeah? The
French... the French hate this
-as well? -Complaining and...
-French people are
-always outraged though.
Sacre bleu. -Yeah. Yeah.
-Come on. That's-that's why
-(mocking laugh)
-I'm not surprised, right?
-Mmm. -Yeah.
-That's just normal to me.
-Absolutely.
I mean, I-I think also what it
is is some... you know...
whatever you want to call it,
the silent majority is losing
certain ground, culturally
speaking, in the culture war.
I mean, in essence, they've
been, like, manspreading, right,
for a long time and putting
their balls here and there
-and...
-I don't know.
The silent majority
is manspreading?
I'm just trying to break it down
so everybody can understand,
you know what I'm saying? I
could stay up here, you know...
-I like that analogy.
-Thank you. Thank you. I just...
I just tucked my legs in,
by the way.
-You just stopped manspreading?
-The silent majority's balls
-are spreading out over... -Yes.
Well, no, they have spread
-far and wide over a lot of...
a lot of people, -Okay.
in their eyes and stuff.
And it's like, "Hey, enough."
-You know? Um... -Where
do you think that anger's from?
I think if people are angry now,
wait till they see
Trump-Trump presidency.
They'll be angry as (bleep).
-(audience reacting)
-See? They mad already. -Wow.
-He didn't even win yet and
they're mad. -It's becoming...
I think
that might produce sadness.
-I don't know if it'll produce
anger. -People are gonna be
-like, "What?!" -How-how
does it feel like to the rest
of the world? D-Do... When-when
you hear Americans are angry,
does it seem like we're
just petulant children or...
No, no, no, no. I have to say,
when I... I got here,
-and it was the beginning
of the campaign, right? -Mm-hmm.
And you know what, one day,
I was watching television
and it was on mute
and I saw the debate.
And I swear, I thought
it was a game show.
(laughter)
-And, you know, there's guys
-It does kind of feel like that.
-behind the podiums
-Right.
and, you know, just one minute
for the answer. Like, just...
And that's too short.
It's, uh...
You know what I...
Okay, you know what I would do
if I was a candidate and
they would give me one minute
to say something important
to a big country like America?
I would take this minute and
offer it to another candidate
and tell him, "This is for you.
Use it to think, really think
about what you just said."
(laughter, applause & cheering)
-WOMAN: Yeah!
You know, it's interesting,
but it-it...
ELMALEH: Because it's going too
fast even on Twitter. -Yes.
-I know. -Even on Twitter, we
have more characters than that.
-WILMORE: Yeah.
-YARD: Yeah. -CARLOS: Yeah.
It's so interesting, Gad,
is that
what started the whole thrust
of the campaign
was just the small thing
that Trump said,
-when he trashed Megyn Kelly...
-Mm-hmm.
and, like, Rosie O'Donnell
in one sentence,
-race was over at that point.
-Yeah. -YARD: Right.
The trashing of women
launched him into first place
-from the beginning.
-YARD: Wow. -CARLOS: Yeah, yeah.
-Yes. Yeah. -From the beginning
where he called Rosie O'Donnell
"a disgusting pig,"
and pretty much
threw Megyn Kelly under the bus.
-Yeah. -That shows you anger
right there.
-Yeah.
-Why would you get mad...?
Why would you support a guy
who trashes women like that?
People got to be losing their
mind in this country right now.
WILMORE:
But what do you think...?
-(applause and cheering)
-Yeah, all right, tell me.
So what do you think
is fueling it?
Do you think it's jobs?
Do you think it's, uh, taxes?
I mean, when Clinton ran in '92,
he said... he said,
-"It's the economy, stupid."
-CARLOS: Right. -YARD: Mm.
I mean, is Trump saying
"It's the Muslim, stupid"?
I mean, what is his thing?
Is it...?
Trump is saying it's everybody
else except white people
-in America is stupid.
That's what he... -CARLOS: Yeah.
That's what he sounds
like he's saying.
'Cause I said it before.
Trump came out, and his campaign
basically assaulted everybody
-that wasn't Trump
or like Trump. -(laughter)
-"It's the Mexicans! It's the
Chinese!" -WILMORE: Mm-hmm.
"It's the...
it's Middle Easterners
that are coming here
and ruining it."
Ain't got nothing
to do with the people
that have been running
the country forever.
-Yeah. Yeah. -I feel bad. I just
got here. I... you know...
(applause and cheering)
YARD: Ain't got nothing to do
with that. -I...
WILMORE:
Yeah, yeah. Go ahead.
I feel bad because I just
arrived, you know, in America.
YARD & WILMORE:
Mm-hmm.
And so, I don't know
what to think, really.
But it's very interesting
and funny
because I've always think
America is great.
-Mm-hmm.
-That's why I came here.
And I come here,
and I hear this guy.
-He said he's gonna make it
great again. -WILMORE: Mm-hmm.
-CARLOS: Right.
-So...
-I'm confused, so...
-(laughter)
-You know, I get that. I get
that. -ELMALEH: No, no, I mean,
-if it's not great...
-YARD: Yeah.
-...I want my money back!
-YARD: Exactly!
-ELMALEH: Because...
-Exactly. -(applause)
What about the the energy
that's around Bernie Sanders?
Do you think that's angry
energy? Is it restless energy?
-What is it? -CARLOS:
I think it's dissatisfaction.
-People feel...
-YARD: Yes.
-It's crazy. -WILMORE:
It's not anger? Mm-hmm.
It's not anger.
It's anger with...
In some ways,
it is anger with Obama
-that he hasn't gone far enough
to the left. -WILMORE: Mm-hmm.
He hasn't been
progressive enough
for some people's tastes.
You know what I mean?
Like, Guantanamo's still there.
And, uh... and people thought
that was gonna be closed
within the first 100 days.
-WILMORE: Right.
-You know?
I mean, just for example.
Just for example.
YARD: Yeah, I think with Bernie,
people are just sick
and tired of watching
the top two percent
-keep getting more richer
and richer. -Yeah.
I'm angry about that.
I can't speak for other people.
-(applause and cheering)
-WILMORE: Well, there is anger.
But I am very angry about that.
I am very angry.
I think there is an anger
about the divide in the economy.
YARD: Yeah, definitely.
I'm sick of that.
The people at the bottom
keep getting further
and further on the bottom.
YARD:
Not even on the bottom.
Like, people in the middle.
Look, I...
WILMORE: Well, the middle
is disappearing.
I got to watch these people
show off their new yachts
and all this stuff on TV.
-ELMALEH: I show you my yacht?
-In the meantime,
I'm sitting on the train.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm sitting... I'm on TV, and
I got to ride the train to work.
-WILMORE: Right.
-CARLOS: Right.
Next...
You know what I'm saying?
-So, I mean, right...?
-(applause and cheering)
Right, right.
Larry, when I got this job,
I thought
those days was over, brah!
-What's going on?
-CARLOS: It's true.
WILMORE: Right. Let me
ask you this question.
Which candidate...?
There's a lot of...
I think there's fear out there,
too.
Which candidate do you think
scares America the most?
-YARD: I have a tie.
-CARLOS: It's a tie.
-My tie is Ted Cruz
and Donald Trump. -(applause)
And I'm gonna take it
to another level.
WILMORE:
All right.
What's scarier
than those two being pres...
either one of them
being president
is if they run together!
That's even scarier.
-That's not gonna happen.
-Could you imagine
if something happened to Trump,
Cruz is president,
if something happened to Cruz,
Trump is president?
-Yeah. -Y'all think
y'all mad now, do that!
(laughter, applause)
-Do that. Let's see
if you ever smile again! -I...
-We'll be right back!
-YARD: Yeah. No...
(cheers and applause)
ANNOUNCER:
Grab some free tickets
to attend an upcoming
taping of The Nightly Show.